i adore kristen so much and she made the
shoots
so delightful for me and we would do the
fight and we fight and we go all the way
and then they say cut and then we're
like oh my god are you okay did i hurt
you did i pull your hair i'm so sorry
honey this is exactly what the world
needs right now some wonder woman 1984
can i tell you and then the on
screen chemistry and the deep love
connection
between diana and steve omg yes
honey how great did it feel for you to
have chris come back
in this vibrant new decade in addition
it felt so good uh i mean
chris was uh one of the
biggest reasons to why wonder woman the
first one was
was such a big success and i couldn't
imagine doing another one without him so
the fact that you know they figured out
the right way to bring him back
that actually helps the story it was
delightful to work with him again and it
felt like coming back home
working with patty and with steve and
with our wonderful crew
it was just it was really really great
what a family you guys have created and
you all are just nailing the sequel and
of course you were nailing the 80s as
well with the fashion the shoulder pads
here the parachute pants you know what
i'm ready to go
i think we can do better parachute pants
yeah um does everybody parachute now but
honey
is there one trend that just needs to
stay in the 80s
of course the fanny pack
who can pull off a fanny pack is chris
right so it was okay with him but in
general
i mean i mean fanny now i need
i need you to tell my mama that that's
for sure
i'm showing her honey we got to talk
about those epic fight scenes
you have quite the showdowns with miss
kristen wig
i don't want to get into too many i know
the one and only
i love how you guys have been become
just like fast friends as well but
how much wire work and how much
physicality had to go into some of these
showdowns the two of you had
a lot i mean uh
look this movie it was from the
very beginning very very ambitious and
and
you know we really took it to the next
level and
petty made a point about wanting as
minimum amount of cgi in the movie which
meant
that we had to do most of the stuff
by ourselves and if not us then our
wonderful stunt team came on board and
took over
but that you know what it's so
interesting
because part of the reasons why we shot
the movie for
such an extended period of time was
because of the
the action stuff it just takes time
we had to prefer it to rehearse it then
you got to build those
incredible incredibly complicated sets
in order for us to do all the wire work
the mall
uh the first action sequence that you
see in the movie
we took over um an abandoned
mall from the 80s and we completely
dressed it up
like the 80s and then the entire ceiling
was covered with wire
rigs and like all these things and i
think that
almost everything that you see there is
either me or my stunt girls
and then the fight that i had with
cheetah we had to feel
to build an entire stage they that can
hold the whole wire rigs
like it was so complex and it was
never really done before so yeah it took
a lot of work uh
i won't lie but i think that it's worth
it because you know it's like
watching a film that was shot on film
versus digitally it's like that it's
like you see
with the way with the weight and the
speed and
our facial facial expressions you see
that it's real people
well now it's my turn
get used to it it is so authentic and
did you and kristen ever hit the gym
together to train for some of these
things
yeah yeah yeah we did we did we had many
rehearsals together
so as far as stance goes we you know i
practice with her stunt girl
she practiced with mine and then they
brought us together and we had to
do the fights together and it was so
funny because
you know we i adore kristen so much
and she made the shoots so delightful
for me just because she was there for me
and
she became a very close friend friend of
mine um
but we would laugh and sing and dance
and like do
silly things on set and then when
they'll roll we'll go to
completely you know in character mode
and we would do the fight and we fight
and we go all the way and then they say
cut and then we're like oh my god are
you okay did i hurt you did i
did i pull your hair i'm so sorry like
oh baby
and then we hug and we're like it was
fun it's crazy
oh you gals are awesome i love it i love
it now you've
obviously we've chatted about the
extreme measures for some of the
physicalities in this
film but honey if i remember correctly
you were five months pregnant while
shooting some of the scenes
in the first film i was pregnant i was
five months pregnant when we did the
reshoots
for uh two and a half weeks for wonder
woman
and that was funny yeah you are the real
life that was an experience i wouldn't
go back to
it wasn't it was a lot um but yeah
i mean surely it was a little easier go
this time around rather than
five months right
you really are the real life wonder
woman but is it any of your little
amazons do they come to set
and watch mama my girls of course look
so the thing is we really became family
patty's family and my family are
really close our husbands our children
and we made sure
to bring them all on sets we shot
sometimes during the weekends for a very
long
days and you know for a long period of
time so
of course they came to set and they
helped
you know the kids helped out giving away
sides to everybody
and sitting by by the village the video
village
and when we were shooting on locations
they were always there
it's they're part of the circus you know
we can do it by ourselves it takes a
village
it most definitely does and we see the
amazonian village that young diana comes
from
they share with her this wisdom that
honey your time will come
right you know and i it was such a
powerful scene but what is like a
teaching a sentiment
wisdom that you hope you're able to
instill within your own children
that there's no shortcuts and there's no
easy ways and there's no free meals
and you gotta work hard in order to
enjoy the you know good results
um so with my kids i just you know i
want them to
enjoy always enjoy the process and
always know
that it's okay to fail and it's great to
go ahead and try again
but essentially i want them to have like
the motivation and the hunger
to pursue whatever it is that they want
to pursue
it's like you gotta do something real
that will fill
you and will make you feel valuable
and and and that will keep your
your mind and your brain stimulate
and you just gotta you just gotta work
hard that's there's no secrets
the secret is that there's no secrets in
order to
do something great you really gotta work
hard for it